MICHAE AMERICA
WHAT IS THNET WOULOTE THAT THE S
IS AT WO
YOIM THE
RUSSIAN UNITS THATT
UKRAINIANS TO  AND KAT IAN GENEI
HELPED KYI SINK THE
WE UNCY LA
RUSSIAN SAILERS DIED IN THE
ATTACK, THRE SIG CASUALTIES.
TT OF VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S INVASION OTWGO
EST BIDEN WAS INSISTENT HE
A
CONTEST BETWEEN THE U. AND
RUSSIA.
III.CONFRO RUSSI
SO T
PREVENT. FEARING POTENTIAL NAR
PUTIN WITHANRVENTINDUR
THAT HBACK
WHKR BRT, THE U.S. AT
G
DS REJEON OVER FEAR COULD
NATO AND RUS
BU DISCRN
THAT DECISIOTO Y S PROXY
CONSIDER THIS TH
D BILLIONS
D
TO V O UKRAINE, THAT'S IN ADDI
PAT WANTS NGRESS TO TAKE UP.
ADIALS A
ADAMANT THERE ARE CLEAR LI THE .
POIOR RUSSIABYTE
CROSSING A LINE WITHSK
KERE TNES WHAT PENTAGOPRESS
HAD TO  ILD
INTELLT WE PROVIDE TO EGAL.U THH
ITEGANE VERYEFUL ABOUT
WH WANE OME CUD FORMERES
LI TINN FOR ITSELF A
AR M UTE
ASSESSES MIGHT PKETHE INF STAD.
THE A.SHAIDEDELD
UKRAIN TT OFF
TION.EF THATORT, WILTH NOTD RE S
. SHARG OFITARY ENCE WITRARTE RL
FORMER U.S. AMBASSAD
AND FORM.S. SPPRESENTATIVE FOR E
INNERALSRE.SOFA SL  MIG FIGHTTOU
INHAT'HELP ME UNDERSTAND THE
F OUR EMENT.HT
LLVING ME.TH
RUSS H ATTTHEM.EFENSPROVIDG MI2R
WE.TO ALY POLAND, WE GOT YOUR CK
AND SILATI AE
THEY'RATTACKING THE
N' THA
N SHARINAT
KRNI AAN
THEMSELV'RE NOT FIGH RUSSIANS.
BUT AROR THE WEAPONRY I THINK
ISERFECTLY FIN
>> OKAY. CER POINT THEWE
DORAW
I'M GOING TO PUT O D LLR K
TIMES" REPORTING IHEFOLLOWING,
HAVE BEED OUT WITH
LOCATIONN UKRAINAT THE
WHERGERAD VISITED WA
TED  THENITED HI
MOSTLEADERS.HE
WELL,T THISSEMPOSED RESTRICTIO.
THE'S NO LEGAL BAS IT.
BUT ECT SEESCTLYG NS TARGET
THE
TO TARGET AMERICAN GENERALSYR ES
T.I
ISBAHIS.ENCE OEIR CH
THRUSSIAOBLEMSTH CONTROL.D COMM.
TH
ONAS
HEEDN
UTHAG ON AND
AND IF YOU'RE E IANS G , THEN W
WOULDN'T YOURGG THE
L LEADERSHIP.
>> ARE YOU SURPRISEDARXE SEEMINY
FOR EXAMDOPEAR
WACYHANY ANTICIPATED WOULD HNCHD
STATESIGHT.RST  IBEG PUTIHAS DOJ
TRIED TO TAHE.D  FORTH.
ANEYOLS.
THEYOMS.E  NSTRAINT .
T YOSEEINGEN
VERY GOOBER .AVE HAD THEIR OWTTI
D RUSSIANS K
MIGHT  WOULD BCAPAESF THEY WSE N
CYBEAGAINSEM
H TS  T GTHERE' OTHE
OUT
CAUSE .SSIA HAS NO,
THEY HAVEN'T DONCLDO.
T THEY MAY BE DETERRED
FRHA STR
BOUT IS TH AI INK THEY HAVE TO
RE
E WORRIED ABOUT AT. QUESTION,E
>> WE ARE NO
WEPOSITION OF HELPING
UKE.DEFEND ITSELF AGAINSA  A
, OUT R
PO SOMEWHERE AND
IR GA
WAR AGAINSTHER IS RUSSEC EXTERME
LI